miss Tyson I asked some of the women who
join me in calling you our queen to
describe you in one word who was on text
this morning they all fled it in with
answers the pizza and yong-go said she's
vibrant taraji Henson said she's a
treasure aunjanue Ellis unparalleled
Regina King authentic Cynthia Revo rege
Shonda Rhimes legendary the mandala
Steinberg groundbreaking Annina no Kiros
our gift Gabrielle Union unapologetic
Kerry Washington divine Ella Davis our
muse an Oprah Winfrey said without
hesitation noble she is nobility
personified all of these words were
offered with deep respect deep love for
you as is my offering my word is flower
in the way that the painter Georgia
O'Keeffe said of flowers but she said a
flower is relatively small compared to
the rest of the universe everyone has
many associations with the flower the
idea of flowers still in a way nobody
sees a flower really we haven't taken
time to truly look and to notice to see
takes time Georgia O'Keeffe Road I said
to myself I'll paint what I see but the
flowers to me but I'll paint it big and
they'll be surprised and they'll have to
take the time to look at it and I'll
make even the busiest people take time
to see what I see the flowers I made
people take time to look you made us
take time to look you are magnificent
miss Tyson are not only the flower
itself you are the maker of the flower
you are the seed for so many of us and
the Rose that we adore we blossom
because of you and for you this is not
truly of black actresses and
storytellers that you've encouraged and
empowered and enlightened and inspired
but of all actors all storytellers all
film lovers all colors all Creed's all
cultures I hope you know that
you have embraced this experience called
life with vigor and Verve and vitality
and you've emerged victorious in this
journey through this industry you've
triumphed in historic ways that will
speak to us for generations and so a
great respect on behalf of the entire
Academy we're proud to honor you tonight
and to finally say and the winner is
Cicely Tyson
[Applause]